[Music]
there are so many new beauty products
being released all the time so we
gathered some of the most hyped to test
for ourselves first up we have the
l'oreal freshware foundation in a powder
i have zero experience with powder
foundation so this one made me nervous
this stuff is full
coverage like covered all of my dark
spots and acne no problem the
application was surprisingly smooth and
i didn't notice any dry patches and all
of my other products layered so well
over it
here's what it looked like eight hours
later i did get oily but i still feel
like the foundation looks beautiful
the ecotools bio bioblender makeup
sponge is a 100 biodegradable makeup
sponge which is so exciting this sponge
blends really really well it's a bit
firmer in texture but i didn't mind and
the shape lets you get into those hard
to blend areas it's recommended that you
compost it after 30 days which at five
bucks a sponge isn't terrible it also
comes in a hundred percent plantable
packaging which is such a cool touch
the sally hansen hydrate peel off nail
mask treatment is like a little tiny
peel-off mask for each of your nails
it's meant to relieve dry nails and
cuticles you just apply a layer to each
nail and peel off after 15 minutes i
definitely did too thick of a layer on
my nails so it didn't peel perfectly but
my nails and cuticles felt nice
afterwards it does feel like a gimmicky
sort of product but still fun to use
i finally got my hands on the abh brow
freeze and there is a reason why this
stuff is sold out everywhere this stuff
is amazing it definitely gives your
brows that laminated fluffy look with
little to no effort this is what it
looks like on my brows with no makeup i
just wanted to see how it made them look
without filling them in and they look so
full it also has serious staying power
here's what my brows looked like at the
end of the day and there's not a hair
out of place
the ordinary concealer claims to be full
coverage but i feel like it's more
medium you could probably build this up
if you wanted to i definitely got the
wrong shade because my skin hasn't seen
the sun in ages but i'm not super in
love with this i feel like my dark under
eyes weren't super covered and i hate
this sort of packaging for concealers i
just feel like i've tried better
concealers at this five dollar price
point but one great thing is that it
does have a diverse range of shades and
undertones
i was so excited to try out the milk
makeup color chalk because milk is one
of my favorite brands but i think this
one is a miss it's definitely
a chalk it's pretty dry and it needs
some moisture to spread easier so i used
my setting spray to help i feel like i
had to apply a lot to get the payoff
that i wanted which normally wouldn't
bother me but this thing is so tiny it's
unbelievable like this tiny thing 15
the packaging is also kind of messy but
it is refillable which i like and i
actually ended up loving this coppery
orange color
[Music]
you